[Music]
season 20 a big brother kind of a return
to its original form Co vets this season
nope all newbies we learned our lesson
last season when we brought back Paul
and he had just played it the summer
previously it wasn't fresh and we wanted
like a fresh coat of paint Rachel do you
recognize my voice these punishments for
the first two weeks Sam as the robot
Casey with the wheel of doom those
didn't seem so fair to me
not only are those punishments not so
fair but the two competitions that each
woman and it was two different
competitions had to take part in warrant
we're not fair
Casey's competition that really was a
game of chance yeah not luck
Sam's competition she had more control
over her fate okay well you know what
her punishment ended up there was a
silver lining there if she wasn't a
robot for half the time in the house I'm
not so sure she would have been the most
trending houseguest most trending isn't
about most popular and least trending
isn't about most dislike it's everyone
was buzzing about her because she got
saddled with that congratulations you
are the top trending houseguest please
browse the available power apps and make
your selection bonus life sounds the
best to me for the whole length of how
long I'm gonna be
she has a chance to return to the game
yes what does that mean that means if
tonight the majority of the House vote
to evict her she will have to
immediately stand up and announce that
she is the one who was trending the most
and the reason you were using the word
chance to stay in the game is because
she has to complete a challenge during
the live show something I will present
her with and if she can complete that
challenge and win the game then she goes
back downstairs and rejoins everybody
and then no one goes home and it stays a
house of 16 and it stays a house of 16
where is she when she's a robot she is
in a little room across from the
soundstage isolated by herself okay and
then when she sleeps at night she is off
campus somewhere else in a separate
house by herself by the way it's
probably vacation just came too early
yes it would have been great mid season
when you've kind of had enough of
everybody got a break this was tough
because she's just trying to get to know
everybody yeah yeah but it also takes a
target off her back she's not in there
long enough to like fight with someone
or really annoy someone but I think she
earned points and it might hurt her she
was so good in the competition the power
veto and the girls are like she's a
beast so one hand you're like oh I
respect that
now do I want to target her for it or do
I want to get into an alliance with her
before it we shall see she's certainly
likeable yes very likeable if you had to
call a winner today who do you think it
would be I wouldn't say Tyler he's been
playing the game and he's been playing
it well and he has no enemies do you
think with Tyler being HOH for so long
that that puts a target on his back
moving for no he's another one who had
played it so safe I think he's playing
an excellent game
he's certainly likable he's believable
he's not he's playing all sides of the
house but not in like this unlikable
slimy way he's doing it in a smart way
he's keeping his lies straight and he's
he's a lot smarter you know when he
first moved in I was like oh
Sean Penn's character Spicoli from Fast
Times at Ridgemont High but that's not
the case at all
and I think outside of the house he
strikes me as someone who is a good
person I mean anyone who wants to save
the oceans cannot be a bad guy true fair
so Tyler's your predicted winner at this
point yeah who is somebody you think we
should keep an eye on that might
surprise us I think Sam you know like
she's been holding her own and she
hasn't even been in the house as herself
so now it's a matter of and we know
she's good at competitions this woman is
a welder she's fearless you know she's
not too precious to get in there she's a
fighter so she she's definitely one to
watch she's going I'm watching she's the
most entertaining to me so far she is
great she is great that way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]